déjà vous allez voir cette vidéo d'une
jeune fille d'une dame qui s'appelle
gisèle qui n'en peut plus regarder et
shell sont bien rangés et tu trouves des
chaises déplacer les assiettes qui se
déplacent toutes seules les ampoules et
qui s'éteint qui sait à lui tout seul
c'est c'est des choses vraiment que qui
font peur j'attends juste qu'on essaie
de nous aider parce que l'on peut pas
dire comme ça surtout quand on travaille
on ne dort pas la nuit mon fils de 14
ans il dort avec moi dans ma chambre sur
deux parce que les nuits il y a
quelqu'un qui lui s'appuyer les pieds
walid vous êtes avec nous on devait nous
raconter tout ça juste avant le meilleur
le maire a d'ailleurs promis qu'ils se
rendraient sur place il explique qu'il
prend les choses très au sérieux regarde
c'est la première fois dans la mer que
nous avons ce type de phénomène qui est
sûr c'est que nous on prend les choses
au sérieux parce que de toute façon il
ya une forme de souffrance qui s'exprime
moi je vais recevoir les familles une
par une des temps les gens qui viennent
et puis on va se mettre en lien avec le
bailleur pour qu'il fasse une inspection
un petit peu du bâtiment j'habitais là
bas depuis combien de temps moi j'habite
je suis mais
je suis là depuis 20 ans maintenant
d'accord je sais que j'achète walid il y
encore cette choqué très sensible voilà
par tout ce qui se passe on dîne en 2019
il ya un habitant qui est mort dans
l'immeuble et depuis ce jour il ya des
phénomènes très étrange qui s'y produit
c'est ça vous connaissiez ce monsieur je
le connaissais très vaguement je vois ce
geste et qui lui disait bonjour etc mais
voilà quoi c'était un voisin d'accord
donc
et il a donc il est humain il est décédé
en 2009 exactement
très vite qu'est ce qui se passe dans
l'immeuble alors
il ya beaucoup de voisins qui se
plaignent qu'ils voyent des ombres
il ya beaucoup de passage des portes qui
claquent
il ya beaucoup de phénomènes vraiment
bizarre tels que les appareils qui
s'allument tout seul
et
pour ma part moi j'ai une histoire
c'était quand je rentrais un jour je
rentrais tard le soir
je rentrais dans le bâtiment externe et
j'ai senti une odeur très nauséabonde
il servir que j'avance etc et je me dis
que c'est vraiment bizarre parce que
d'habitude voilà quoi ça sentait
vraiment les égouts etc je me dis mais
ça quand j'étais à l'extérieur ça
sentait pas ça et donc j'avance et je
sens une présence derrière moi et comme
si on m'a attrapé les pôles donc moins
paniqués je me retourne d'un coup et je
vois rien du tout voilà donc c'est à
dire que depuis ce jour là j'essaye de
ne pas trop rentrer le soir tard le soir
voilà quoi c'est vous avez vécu d'autres
phénomènes
j'ai vécu d'autres phénomènes
j'entendais des pas en fait dans les
escaliers encore le soir en moi c'est et
il n'y avait personne parce que les
portes claquent et on entend des portes
claquer
colombelles est-ce que c'est dans
l'immeuble où aussi dans les
appartements il se passe des choses
aussi alors dans les appartements il se
passe des choses que j'ai des
témoignages de voisins qui veulent
rester en amont en anonyme s'il y en a
très peu et on en parle parce qu'ils ont
peur ah oui parce qu'il ya beaucoup de
journalistes juste aujourd'hui on a eu
dix ou je ne sais pas nationale c'est
une histoire de fous et voilà de créer
dire que nous en ont marre un peu et
surtout bas par rapport aux 6 par
rapport à bfm tv comment ils ont pris le
reportage etc c'est un peu comme s'il
était là en mode
caricatural exactement alors exactement
donc terre vous trouvez qu'ils n'ont pas
pris la faire assez au sérieux voilà
exactement
aujourd'hui il se passe énormément de
choses dans l'immeuble où aline va nous
dire ce qui se passe également je sais
que vous avez des infos et tout ce qui
se passe dans cet immeuble alors on va
rappeler site à fontenay-aux-roses c'est
assez dense et dans
92 et les habitants sont terrifiés c'est
aussi pour ça qu'ils ne veulent pas
venir parce que dans leur esprit il y a
des forces presque entre guillemets
maléfique il ya du mal dans l'immeuble
c'est à dire que après la mort du
résident il ya des gens qui dans la vie
quotidienne est bouleversée c'est ça ils
ne peuvent plus vivre et apparemment le
maire ces biens est venu mais c'est pas
une situation suffisantes pour avoir un
relogement donc pour le moment il n'y a
pas d'issue on les oblige presque à
rester mais ils peuvent plus vivre les
enfants peuvent plus travailler à
l'école spaf ils peuvent pas faire leur
devoir c'est à dire que vous avez un
enfant qui dort par exemple il est
réveillé il appelle sa maman parce qu'il
a une présence qui le chatouille vous
avez des des appareils qui ne marchent
plus tôt d'autres qui se met en place
tout seul ces gens ne peuvent plus
s'alimenter ne peuvent plus travailler
plus cher leur devoir ils sont épuisés
mentalement parce qu'il ya énormément de
dépression de lima plein de dépression
c'est à dire que ça tous sur le système
mentale et honnêtement ces familles ne
vivent plus ne peuvent plus vivre là
c'est qu'il faut trouver une solution il
ya monsieur va peut-être nous le dira
mais il ya une présence il ya des forces
qu'on peut qualifier de culte mais très
concrète qui bouleverse leur vie assez
dramatique et on le voit vous êtes très
courageux d'être venu donc parce que ces
gens se demandent s'ils parlent qu'est
ce qui va leur arriver on en est là on
en est là votre vie est
depuis 2009 depuis la mort de cette
personne me 10,9 genre à peine trois ans
c'est sa trois ans l'art après on peut
avoir toutes les interprétations qui
était cette personne pourquoi cette
personne qu'est-ce qui peut ressortir
après mais très concrètement depuis
trois ans 7 ce lieu n'est plus habitable
par des gens c'est impossible de vivre
là où vous vivez et vous êtes très
courageux monsieur franchement alors il
ya aussi beaucoup va nous raconter
stress passeur
raconter ce qui sera soit une autre
chose et ce qui se passe pour les
habitants de cet immeuble on aura
l'analyse de jean didier dans un instant
juste question oui de delphine qui avait
relevé la même question donc en fait ça
doit sans doute être l'âme errante de ce
monsieur
moi je sais que ça existe enfin j'y
crois j'ai j'ai vécu des choses mais
est-ce que vous avez déjà parlé avec les
enfants de l'immeuble parce qu'en fait
nous chacun lorsqu'on est enfant on voit
des choses est en fait en grandissant on
se dit tellement que c'est pas possible
qu'on ne le voit plus est-ce que je suis
sûr qu'en par l'anc des enfants entre je
sais pas entre trois et quatre ans ils
sentent des choses que les adultes ne
voit pas cette sixième sens
soulisse est exactement il ya une
voisine qui est une voisine tuyaux qui
m'a raconté que sa fille avait vu
quelque chose et l avons suivi sa fille
est en fait sa team montré du doigt
quelque chose mais que voilà quoi elle
avait vu un petit enfant courir dans les
enfants alors à la criée enfin voilà
qu'à la criée et ans l'enfant mais elle
était encore un petit alors quand ils
vont nous rejoignent à 20h44 on est en
direct cette histoire est vraie cette
histoire est folle ça se passe à
fontenay-aux-roses à quelques kilomètres
d'ici là 92 c'est là où habite daniel et
c'est vrai que tout le monde prend cette
histoire très très au sérieux un
immeuble qui serait apparemment on tait
depuis la disparition d'un des habitants
oui béatrice est ce qu'à un moment donné
quelqu'un a essayé de faire venir à
l'exorciste un prêt vous quelqu'un qui
fait une des cérémonies comme ça de
nettoyage énergétique
c'est plus sain dans de longues et donc
dans ce que j'entends c'est plus un
passeur d'âmes dont on a besoin parce
que effectivement
alors pour moi moi je ressens deux
entités à la base ce soir je suis médium
depuis 35 ans et que j'ai évolué
progressivement sur de la chasse aux
fantômes et sur tout ce qui touche les
phénomènes paranormaux en devenant
experts de cette partie et quand
j'entends ce discours
je suis pas du tout choquée parce que
pour moi le paranormal cdu normal qu'on
ne comprend pas encore aujourd'hui mais
qui fait partie de notre vie de tous les
jours alors avant c'était dans les
châteaux qu'on allait chasser les
fantômes et on disait qu'il y avait des
entités dans les fantômes dans les
fantômes par nantes ranger dans les
habitations et dans les châteaux mais
aujourd'hui il faut savoir que dans les
maisons dans les hlm il y a aussi des
entités se promènent dès qu'ils sont
joints à la suite d'un décès et moi je
sortais effectivement deux une petite
fille doit jouer une petite fille et je
pense qu'il est parce que y'a trop de
phénomènes paranormaux qui s'échelonne
sur plusieurs étages et sur plusieurs
maisons enfin
[Musique]
si
la tumeur
est alors en fin de compte quand quand
il ya juste une entité qui se trouvent
bloqués dans un endroit elle est dans un
endroit et ne bougent pas de cet endroit
ou très peu par contre après elle peut
se déplacer et s'il est une autre entité
qui est plus anciennes ou qui a aussi
vécu et chanté elle peut se manifester
les chiens en pèse sur verrière dire
adieu arrêtent d'agir a dit non mais moi
je tresse a aussi dit aux gens tout
m'est insupportable
oui donc avant avant la disparition de
ce monsieur ne mentionnait rien on est
d'accord il n'est pas dans un état
catastrophique il n'est pas un salut
bien pas des problèmes avec moi tu crois
que cette histoire
ça correspond vraiment à la mort de ce
monsieur n'à rien après en fait il ya
quelques voisins qui disent c'était deux
ans avant aussi raté quelques voilà
c'est ce que je disais pour moi faisons
quelque chose il ya une petite fille moi
je sens une petite fille qui était
malade et qui a dû succomber à des
problèmes de toxicité sa
femme et l'enfance et la petite fille
oui il ya une petite faim pendant qu'on
parle d'une petite fille qui est qu'il
n'est pas dans le même temps je mens que
ce monsieur est un logement juste à côté
gentil dit juste c'est ça parle de quoi
en fait un immeuble hanté comme ça parce
que son fils éric en région parisienne
ça c'est la première fois que jean
pierre sarthou de mort partout et tout
le temps oui mais comment faire comment
je vais vous expliquer en fin de compte
pourquoi ça se passe
des fois vous avez des maisons qui sur
lequel il va y avoir des gens qui vont
venir habiter qui vont déménager
d'autres vont prendre la succession etc
et pendant 20 30 ans il va strictement
rien se passer et puis d'un seul coup
vous avez des gens qui arrivent et eux
ils captent des choses ils ont des
ressentis ils sont des présentes il ya
des lumières qui s'allument qui éclate
un petit peu comme d'expliquer tout à
l'heure on va tendre qu'est ce qui s'est
passé c'est qu'il ya une personnes
réceptives qui est arrivé dans cet
endroit là qui avait certainement une
capacité médiumnique mais qu'il ne
savait pas ou en tout cas qui était un
hypersensible et qui est rentré d'une
certaine façon en contact avec cette
entité il faut savoir que tous les
domaines où les autres après tout les
autres ressentent aussi se ressentent
aussi alors pas forcément mais c'est ce
qui se passe et que la sensibilité c'est
un peu comme l'égrégore ça se propage
partout et la sensibilité tout le monde
va car il faut savoir que effectivement
tout ça ce sont des choses que l'on
trouve fréquemment mais beaucoup de
personne n'ose pas en parler ils ont
peur de se faire ridiculiser
ils ont peur du qu'en dira-t-on ils ont
peur de tout un tas de l'immeuble ces
cas mais ça arrive pour limoges c'est
catastrophique la folie est complètement
ci et là enfin quand le maire sait très
bien ce qu'il fait mais malheureusement
ces problèmes
les bailleurs d'ailleurs
c'est de faire jean-didier parce qu'il
est concrètement ce qu'il est possible
de faire c'est de venir checker sur
plaque exactement ce qui se passe s'il
ya effectivement une deux entités ou 3
et de voir où elle se trouve dans quel
appartement d'essayer de retrouver
l'historique en plus l'historique
justement à la mairie ou au commissariat
ou autre on peut retrouver quand elle
les personnes qui sont décédées
généralement on arrive à le savoir quand
on a après ces faits là on demande un
passeur d'âmes de venir parce qu'en fait
contre 16 entités sont bloqués entre
deux mondes et elle n'arrive pas à
dépasser ça et à passer à autre par donc
là c'est un appel au secours c'est un
apéro les enquêtes encadré ci dessous
d'accord elle va participer elles
veulent partir dans la petite elle veut
partir au site mais l appel au secours
et pour appeler au secours il faut
qu'elle tombe sur un individu qui est
une certaine forme de sensibilité ou
voir d'hypersensibilité qui va capter ça
et qui va capter ces messages et à
partir ça va fonctionner mais c'est pas
grave c'est pas dramatique d'accord et
c'est pas non plus
quelque chose qu'il développe ou vente
jeudi impressionnant mais les antiques
les jours j'ai trouvé l on que ce moyen
là pour se manifester pour rentrer en
contact avec nous donc ça c'est un coup
d'arrêt ce qu'on n'est pas les
surveillants n'ont pas de vision
géomètre personnes valides dans cet
immeuble
alors chiens environ 15 personnes et les
quinze tout on sait vision ces problèmes
voilà quelques-unes qu'il renie rien et
on a 10 à viadana 5 qui ne ressentent
rien qu'ils en tirent possible en haut
qu'en bas si oui c'est possible parce
que ça dépend de la sensibilité de
chaque individu d'accord et
effectivement quand on est hyper
sensible de marans capte automatiquement
les choses à puissance 10 cents ou mille
alors que d'autres ne la capte pas et
comme il a été dit aussi tout à l'heure
quand on est enfant on à la fontanelle
qui est ouverte pour les enfants pour
les bébés et on est ouvert sur le monde
extérieur et sur le paranormal et
surtout ce qui peut se passer sur ce
plan là c'est alors que l'âge ça se
referment et du coup on redevient dans
le quasi mono rejoignent à 20h40 on est
en direct à 20h51 avec walid où il
habite cette maison cet immeuble en t
mais ça peut paraître fou mais un
immeuble serait hanté entre guillemets 1
c'est dans la région parisienne dont 92
même le maire prend les choses très au
sérieux que ça avec tous les
journalistes sont sur cette affaire
c'est avec personne ne veut parler
personne n'ose parler voilà dans cet
immeuble walid a été le seul à bien
vouloir témoigner ce soir et walid pour
les téléspectateurs qui nous rejoignent
vous donc vous avez dit vous avez reçu
sorti une première fois une présence
quelqu'un qui vous toucher l'épaule il
ya des habitants de l'immeuble qui qui
ont des voilà des choses qui se mettent
en route tout seul des lumières qui
s'allument c'est un marche plus les
enfants qui voient avec présent
exactement des enfants qui voient des
prénoms est ce qu'il ya eu des choses
graves qui se sont passées ou est ce
qu'il ya eu voilà des gens qui ont eu
des voilà qui ont eu des idées senti des
violences ou des choses mais ou pas du
tout ce qui est des trucs grave ou bien
c'est que voilà des choses comme adjoint
didier deschamps il va d d d d esprit
qui pourrait se manifester mais sans
agressivité ou sans voilà c'est ce qui a
eu des délais les choses des violences
des trucs moi je ne ressens rien si je
peux me permettre elle ne ressent rien
maléfique d'accord très bien je sais
simplement des entités qui veulent se
faire entendre d'accord mais vous vous
ressentez rien dit si elle veut le
comprendre pas si vous ressentez rapport
à monsieur ne vous êtes pas allé dans
l'immeuble non si c'était votre mail
que j'ai mais en tout cas ce qu'il a dit
vous avez vu que c'était plutôt exact ce
que raconte grande idée depuis tout à
l'heure ouali donc il ya eu des choses
un peu plus graves qui sont passés ou
pas du tout
déjà on voit beaucoup de personnes la
plupart de l'immeuble ils sont en
dépression c'est ça il ya des
changements d'humeur en fait de
personnes du bâtiment assez dire que du
jour au lendemain joris en plus énervé
que
que d'habitude quoi c'est à dire qu'il
ya vraiment cette dépression ils sont
vraiment tristes ils sont à bout de
nerfs entre exactement à cela une bande
plus l'admin exactement ils dorment plus
la nuit parce que quand quand la télé ça
lui tout seul alors que la télécommande
bah voila quoi elle est juste à côté
bien sûr c'est jean didier est ce que ça
est-ce que viendra quand vous dites ces
entités est ce qu'elles peuvent voilà
faire du mal logiquement sciemment ou
est ce que c'est parce que c'est la
fatigue qui fait qu' il ya dans ces
immeubles énormément dépression oui les
habitants sont au bout du rouleau sais
ce que c'est parce qu'ils sont fatigués
parce qu'ils sont il est vrai ils sont
sous pression mais c'est ce qui se passe
tout simplement que c'est qu'on n'est
pas habitué on n'est pas confronté est
tout le temps à ce genre de phénomène
donc ça fait peur mais en fin de compte
ce que je dis toujours moi les fantômes
sont gentils fantômes cd ils sont très
gentils ils veulent simplement rentrer
en contact avec nous et ils veulent le
comprendre ce qui se passe et ils
veulent comprendre pourquoi ils sont
bloqués en attendant que ces deux mondes
et on les a aidés à partir voilà donc
après il ya un rééquilibrage à faire
j'ai écrit un livre sur le pouvoir
magique des pierres et des cristaux et
sur ce livre j'explique avec des
cristaux on utilise beaucoup la pleine
lune justement parce que hier c'était
appelé nul on utilise les cristaux la
pleine lune pour recharger et puis pour
aussi aider ces entités à part sierre
c'est sa voix parce qu'il ya énormément
énormément de réactions sur ce sujet et
c'est vrai que ici tout prend cette
affaire très au sérieux moi le moi le
premier je vous le dis c'est incroyable
on dit voilà oui vous avez plein de
questions benjamin bien est-ce que c'est
lié à la mort violente on est parfois
que quand vous d'avoir est très très
violent très violent benjamin sa
réaction en fin de compte ce qui se
passe c'est que il ya une
incompréhension c'est à dire que souvent
quelqu'un qui va mourir d'un assassinat
ou d'une crise cardiaque n'a pas le
temps de réagir un appartement de
comprendre ce qui lui arrive et ce qui
se passe soit ils avaient les messages à
transmettre soit il avait des choses à
dire qu'il n'a pas eu le temps de dire
soit il est attaché à une personne
auxquelles il est encore amoureux donc
il n'arrive pas à comprendre qu'il
puisse pas continuer à transmettre cet
amour soit il est attaché à un endroit
moi j'ai eu un cas il ya quelques années
avec un monsieur qui avait construit sa
maison et qui est décédé et ne voulait
pas que sa maison soit vendu parce que
c'était lui qui avait construit cette
maison et parce que il était attaché à
cette maison et il avait demandé à sa
femme de ne pas vendre cette maison et
sa femme quand il est parti à la vente
de la maison et ce qui s'est passé c'est
pendant le compromis et les actes
authentiques de vente la maison a brûlé
il ya des choses les fois qu'ils sont
très surprenantes escaut alors oui et
maintenant qu'il faut les sauver de plus
en plus et nathalie notamment marqué qui
m'écrit pour sauver les âmes qui sont
bloqués demande de l'aide c'est pour ça
qu'elle se manifeste et tous les aider
car par la suite elle pourrait se
prendre sur prendre aux enfants +106
sont plus sensibles c'est vrai exemple
s'en prendre non mais pas effectivement
on rentre dans un mécanisme comme on
disait de dépression de déprimer les
ados peuvent aussi générer ce qu'on a
fait les phénomènes portugaise tout
comme nantes aura donc ils ont entendu
parler enfin commencer des ados qui sont
souvent en révolution et qui extériorise
des choses tellement fort tellement
violentes que par leur énergie il arrive
à créer des phénomènes par un oral et de
deux entités est ce que juste khalid on
sait s'il ya une petite fille qui est
décédée dans cet immeuble également
parce que
non pas du tout mais
moi je sais pas personnellement mais ce
que je sais c'est que la personne qui
est morte qui étaient partis à trois en
1019 à sa femme est morte je crois une
semaine après ou vraiment très
rapidement et la personne qui était
juste en face de son appartement elle a
déménagé et a commencé à aller à la
mairie etc pour se plaindre
il ne prenait pas du tout au sérieux à
voulait vraiment des ménages et externe
en ressentez tout ça et après ces deux
là où tout l'immeuble a commencé à dire
on va essayer de le monsieur je ne sais
pas du tout parce que j'étais sous
denses et quand je suis parti en
vacances et que je suis revenu j'ai vu
qu'il était déjà un peu paralysé déjà
qui bat quand je suis parti étaient deux
en pleine forme et c'est d'accord
vraiment en pleine forme et après quand
je suis son état s'est dégradé à 6,9 ou
non vraiment vite en un mois il était
vraiment
paralysé quoi il marchait plus non moi
c'est ce que ce qu'on pense qu'il n'a
pas compris ce qui lui arrivait parce
que ça allait trop vite alors c'est pas
non plus une crise cardiaque ou c'est
encore beaucoup plus rapide et qu'on
bascule d'un monde à l'autre mais là il
n'a pas eu le temps de comprendre ce qui
lui arrivait et donc c'est quelqu'un
qu'on a besoin d'aidé effectivement à
partir et à ne pas rester attachés au
matériel parce qu'en fin de compte cette
entité était attaché au matériel oui
mathieu et après vous allez rire oui
mais vous allez rire pendant les
épisodes rapide mais dans tous les
immeubles du monde il ya une personne
qui meurt d'une crise cardiaque
syrie veut qu'on perd sa femme qu encore
attachés pourquoi face est là pourquoi
dans cet immeuble de fontenay-aux-roses
syndicat cgsp pied tout à l'heure le
personnes hypersensibles personnes
sensibles médium ou hypersensible qui
est un médium dans l'immeuble voilà tout
ce serait perdre et ça personne ne le
sait pas quel est donc cet accord n'ont
dû qu'à elle a ouvert une porte et enfin
contre les entités qu'est ce qu'ils
attendent elles attendent que cette
porte s'ouvre pour pouvoir communiquer
avec un médium et le pire c'est que si
ce médium ne répond pas parce qu'il ne
sait pas qu'il est médium ou parce que
il a peur des phénomènes paranormaux va
continuer cette cité a généré des
phénomènes paranormaux ce qui se passe
jusqu'à temps que dans l'église je
voudrais que celle qu'on finisse par
m'écouter parier qu'on m'entend vous
avez ouvert une porte vous cherchez à
rentrer en contact avec moi donc
maintenant il faut le faire
mais j'entends tout ce que vous dites et
j'entends la souffrance de monsieur et
je me remet absolument pas en cause son
témoignage est ce que pour autant on
peut peut-être imaginer il ya toute
l'histoire de france a été jalonnée
d'histoire d'hallucinations collectives
ou de voile a aidé de jean qui a eu des
villages ans il ya eu des villages qui
ont été comme ça sur des hallucinations
collectives ou le village entier et
après la médecine hat a dit en fait il
s'agissait du nanisme hallucination
collective est ce qu'on pourrait
imaginer que là parce qu'il y avait
quelqu'un d' extrêmement sensible les
uns et les autres ont été justement
perturbé par sa et l'immeuble lui-même a
fini par par ce pas parce par entendre
des choses voir des choses qui peut-être
ne sont absolument pas paranormal se
pose la question alors si on est
vraiment dans le paranormal là il n'y a
pas de doutes par rapport à ça la seule
chose qui se passe c'est que tu alors je
parle et d'égrener gregor c'est de la
formation don de soi positive soit
négative là on est dans le cas donc
positive ou une entité cherche à rentrer
en contact avec des médiums ou avec des
gens hyper sensible donc ce qui se passe
c'est que les gens qui sont autour c'est
le bouche à oreille ils entendent il ya
la méfiance il ya la peur et à la
crainte donc tout ça elle fait aussi que
psychologiquement il ya quand même une
part de psychologie qui rentrent en
ligne de compte ça c'est indéniable mais
il n'ya pas que de la psychologie a
aussi le paranormal il est 21h si vous
nous rejoignez c'est vraiment le fait du
jour c'est incroyable ce qui se passe
cet immeuble qui seraient hantées
vraiment quelques kilomètres de paris
dans la région parisienne avec des
habitants qui sont au bout du rouleau en
dépression qui sont des présence des
enfants qui se font réveiller la nuit
des télés qui s'allument tout seul des
appareils ménagers qui se casse qui
s'allument des lumières et qui
s'allument également qui s'éteignent des
présences des on vous a tout dit vous
nous racontez vous êtes rentré un soin
vous avez senti une présence derrière
vous quelqu'un vous a pris par l'épaule
et il n'y avait personne c'est vrai que
cette histoire on la prend extrêmement
au sérieux tout l'apprend serre dues
actuellement c'est tout un immeuble
entier ça ne subit ces phénomènes
paranormaux par une dizaine de personnes
sur les casiers personnes qui sont dans
l'immeuble suite au décès d'un habitant
en 2019 walid est avec nous c'est le
seul sachez le ce soir qui a bien voulu
témoigner
affaire tout le monde et tous les
habitants sont extrêmement vraiment dans
un état qui sont dans un état terrible
terrifiée je vous dise ok rien ils ont
peur de parler il faut pas je sais il
faut pas mais on valide je me tourne
vers vous vous aujourd'hui
comme les autres habitants comment vous
appréhendez tous les nuits quand vous
arrivez parce que quand c'est la nuit
vous quand vous mettez y arriver à
dormir vous arriver à un
niveau de vie ou pas du tout plu du tout
moi j'arrive à vivre ma vie normalement
mais avec qui j'ai eus avec mes parents
d'accord auparavant ils sont touchés par
ça aussi oui ma mère est arrivé des
choses à vos parents ma mère altica voix
des fois des présences dans le salon ou
quoi et comme vous et il était lui aussi
qui s'allument chez vous les télés salut
oui d'accord maintenant dans la nuit oui
pendant la nuit cette tranquille en
train d'en miria les ouailles ma mère
les temps la télé il s'avère que l'homme
la voisine est descendu et il m'arrive
la même chose ouais sur cinq donc bon
moi ça m'affecte pas j'essaye de
m'adapter c'est à dire que je rentrerai
plus tard tard le soir parce que je sais
que c'est
alors quoi c'est le soir c'est là où les
présences à s'affirmer viennent iliad il
ya des habitants dans l'immeuble qui
disent on n'en peut plus on sait qu'il
ya énormément énormément de dépression
il ya des gens qui ont arrêté qui sont
mis en arrêt de travail qui est qui qui
peuvent plus vivre une vie normale
exactement et en fait par rapport aux
bas par rapport à ça les gens l'ont
retourné parce qu'on voulait déménager
être relogées plus rapidement alors que
pas du tout parce que en fait notre
bâtiment il est il ya de l'amiante c'est
à dire que toute la barra va être démoli
maintenant il est donc c'est à dire
qu'on était obligés d'être relogés dans
les cinq ans à venir ou dans les dix ans
donc en est on est très bien et si ci
aurait pas tout ça on a un parking
gratuit juste derrière on à
fontenay-aux-roses il ya des gens qui
disent aussi je vous dis je vous donne
jeudi tournage et tous les gens ici qui
disent sur les réseaux est-ce qu'ils
sont pas tous mis d'accord presse que
l'immeuble et les paléo est insalubre
pour faire croire à ses lèvres loire est
peut-être temps ou l'envié mais ccc
voilà c'est justement oui vous avez
entendu cinq ans à venir pour les plus
sceptiques et pour ceux qui doutent de
votre témoignage est-ce que ça sert à
quelque chose de médée vidéosurveillance
partout par exemple alors se voir ses
films plusieurs choses par exemple on
utilise les pistolets à visée laser pour
mesurer les températures parce que quand
il ya des manifestations paranormales
avec des présence d'entités il ya une
chute de température de 2 ou 3 degrés
donc déjà quand on va sur place faire
entre guillemets ce qu'on appelle une
chasse aux fantômes on voit s'il ya déjà
des baisses de température après on peut
mettre des vidéos surveillance mais
généralement les vidéosurveillances tout
ce qui est électronique
la télé s'allume vraiment pardon de sa
saison puisque la télé c'est vraiment à
ce que les bases sont en deuil est ce
que ce sera bien voir que le maire tu
avec des caméras que le maire puisse
devoir parce que la série est juste la
parole de 10 personnes qu'on croit bien
sûr la pole et mais on a bien mettre en
place comme je l'expliqué c'est quelque
chose qui est très connu dans le
phénomène de vente ils ont qu'on le
verrait ses c'est vraiment des choses
que l'on retrouve d'une façon si ce
n'est pas l'impression d'avoir eu la
sensation d'être épié d'avoir quelqu'un
derrière et vous vous retournez puis à
personne certains comme prévu sur la
question serait ce que pour celles qui
se battent et des caméras l'année on le
verrait ça se passerait à voir des to
alors ça a été tenté ça a été fait
mais sans succès jusqu'à parce que c'est
là où je voulais en venir aussi pardon
c'est que ça m'inquiète des expériences
qui ont été faites sur des plateaux télé
ou ailleurs à chaque fois il ya
quelqu'un qui dit oui mais là il ya un
truc qui va pas hésiter qui est négative
qui élèvent ou du côté des caméras et ça
et détente et s'était rien passé mois
sur plusieurs tournages je sais la rue
massey qui est assez étrange c'est que
les cameramen qui venaient avec des
batteries complètement rechargées en
l'espace de deux minutes vie des hs
vider complètement et dans une pièce où
on avait ressenti ses indemnités alors
qu'on allait dans d'autres pièces s'il
se passait rien du tout et là il y avait
des lumières qui commençait à anthony
voter
s'arrêter et wally je voulais revenir
sur votre vie quotidienne parce que vous
êtes très cartésien rigoureux vous
n'avez pas l'air de quelqu'un qui
raconte des histoires aujourd'hui par
exemple est ce que chaque famille le
soir venu le plus tôt possible se
calfeutre est ce que les gens ne sent
plus dans les parties communes et ce cas
une terreur d'aller là où quelqu'un vous
avez touché vous à l'épaule est-ce que
l'avenir tour n'est pas est-ce
qu'aujourd'hui l'immeuble tente de se
fermer de se cloîtrer ans par rapport à
ces phénomènes alors oui les gens ne
sort plus beaucoup de chez eux par
rapport à ça et comme il est ici il ya
même des personnes qui ont eu des arrêts
de travail pour pu aller au travail
excita et
on essaie d'éviter de sortir plus le
soir dans les halls c'est vraiment voilà
la consigne mais sinon
tout le monde reste chez soi il ya des
gens qui n'y croient pas dans les mêmes
lieux rien vu c'est des conneries
oui il ya des gens qui n'y croit pas
mais
il écoute c'est à dire qu' il n'y croit
pas mais il est content parce que y'a
pas tout le monde qui croient tout sa
nature on peut voir les commentaires
sont là là où la majeure partie des gens
de l'immeuble subissent des phénomènes
notamment va dire exactement midi par
168 oui si je sais que ce genre de
témoignage cyril
va faire que dans quelques semaines mais
beaucoup de gens vont se dire pourquoi
et moi n'y aura pas non plus mais nous
arrive exactement la même est ce que
comme on le disait tout à l'heure ça
arrive dans pleins des hlm dans plein de
maisons endroits mais les gens n'osent
pas en parler parce que c'est pas fini
sur la place publique lassée
exceptionnel dès qu'on parle ce soir de
ce cas mais j'ai vu très peu de
démission a accordé autant de temps à ce
type de sujet c'est incroyable béatrice
parce que là en plus on a l'impression
vraiment c'est tout le monde en parle
c'est un hlm ya beaucoup d'anciens de
d'habitude quand on entend on entendu
l'histoire de la maison isolée voilà on
s'est dit bon voilà vieux manoir
voilà avec des différents habitants de
différentes familles qui subissent les
mêmes phénomènes c'est ça alerte quand
même oui béatrice cher si on enlève les
gens qui sont sceptiques et qui pensent
que c'est une manipulation et qu'on
décide de prendre ce témoignage au
sérieux pourquoi quelqu'un comme vous
n'a pas déjà été appelés puisque à une
urgence les gens n'en peuvent plus ils
sont à bout psychologiquement est ce que
vous vous avez l'intention d'y aller ce
que vous avez été appelé pour y aller
oui c'est néanmoins on ne m'a pas fait
de demande mais je suis prêt à le faire
si on peut organiser quelque chose alors
j'habite pas du tout la région
parisienne je suis sur la rochelle n'en
connaissent pas est un petit plus il
faut que je me déshabille crochet il ça
peut se faire si on a réussi à faire
aujourd'hui donc
encore voilà vous êtes pas y aller comme
de regagner sa quand même s'en plaint
500 logements
pour trouver les bons large et aborde
chantôme a reserré payer pour ça
alors maintenant je suis à la retraite
et je fais je me fais pas payer par ci
un peu chaud et
j'ai créé des ouvrages j'ai parlé là ces
ouvrages sont à leur lycée édité au
lotus et les défend voilà je vis de mon
secteur les ouvrages voilà vous le
faites vraiment là pour aider les gens
voilà autant les perdre et des entités
tueries des biens des personnes à fait
moi j'ai eu une adresse mail où les gens
m'écrivent et je reçois des messages
tous les jours et j'essaye de les
rassurer a énormément dire ah oui mais
ils sont pas médiatisés voici ces choses
c'est bon ça va faire que ça va faire sa
valeur mais malheureusement quand ils
sont médiatisés comme il disait tout à
l'heure c'est pas médiatisé
oui mais mathieu à mes questions aussi
vous êtes vous ai dit tout à l'heure
c'est pas et c'est pas grand chose
finalement c'est quelqu'un qui entre
deux portes qui veut aller dans dans
l'au delà si vous vous allez sur place
combien de temps ça vous prend pour
alain c'est un
peu m 10 minutes comme ça peut mettre
cinq heures
d'une journée c'est réglé oui
normalement une jambe et couturiers quoi
devrais refaire un équilibrage des
endroits comme j'écris mais en fin de
compte le problème c'est de réussir à
rentrer en contact avec l'entité
instaurer un dialogue et
de sa valeur en une journée c'est réglé
si vous déplacez donc si vous y allez
gens d'ici
vous allez faire quoi la barre pour être
en contact alors pour rentrer en contact
c'est un peu bizarre parce que enfin
quand on est le dialogue qu'on a là tous
les deux là c'est à dire que je parle à
haute voix à quelqu'un qui est invisible
qui n'ont voulu dire quoi car toi je lui
demande pourquoi il est là pourquoi il
débloqué
en c'est comme dans les films en
médiumnité il ya plusieurs choses ce
qu'on appelle la claire audience et la
clairvoyance donc on l'entend où on voit
les choses et après ce très souvent ça
m'est arrivé aussi de faire des séances
dites de spiritisme pourrait aider plus
facilement l'enquêté est rentré en
contact avec nous il veut délivrer des
messages donc on peut faire ce genre de
choses aujourd'hui penser que vous
réglez la faire alors
ça serait prétentieux de dire que ça
marche dans 100% des cas mais dans 80%
des cas oui si ça fonctionne oui de la
logique parce qu'en fait des âmes
errantes y en a partout donc ça se
trouve ici dans un quart des personnes
qui sont ici on a peut-être une entité
qui traîne à la maison et elle souhaite
se manipule elle se manifeste pas
forcément aussi fortement par exemple
quand vous avez une maison et le couple
divorce ensuite s'est vendu le prochain
couple divorcé comme ça va peut-être il
ya une entité dans la maison
était avec nous
avec sa famille avec son conjoint la
prochaine fois tu m'en voyez quoi je
perds c'est l'entité
cédée il ya des merrell un peu compliqué
par exemple avec mon chéri ou qu'importe
je fais venir souvent un magnétiseur et
irrigue le tout parfois que l'identité
qui est resté collé à moi pas j'étais
fatigué je vais ramener à la maison
alors c'était juste castaldi
[Rires]
c'est d'abord équivoque human bomb
énoncé faire une entité
du bois de là que c'est une entité que
votre écoute arrête tu le vois pas ça
bordel
les fenêtres ont fait brûler delachaux
non tu te voir toi pour la prière on a
une bulle d'énergie sur la maison et
après tout va mieux ouais c'est ce que
je disais tout à l'heure on utilise des
cristaux moi je travaille beaucoup avec
les lectrices tôt donc on utilise
exactement la société où les plaignants
je travaille avec de david hasselhoff
blanche
la sauce harissa
je travaillais dans un kebab
il faut que richier le lieu après le
nettoyer ce qu'on appelle un nettoyage
spirituel tout simplement si la somme
est à travers à travers des prières ben
voilà non non moi je dis dans mes deux
chiens et moi alors je vous dire moi
j'ai craqué j'adorais un dictateur je le
trouve l imec c'est pas jojo je vois
qu'il est sérieux je ne sais pas
moi je vous dis moi jean didier je
trouve extrêmement sérieux et le cookie
dis pas de conneries intègre voilà il
est avec ses pinces pas un mais voilà il
le fait en plus bénévolement voilà et
arrêter les mecs ah bon la joie rien
débattu à habas côtoient et non tu seras
bien content
[Rires]
qu'ils mettaient derrière aujourd'hui
quelques heures
son nicolo donato diesel
j'en dis moi j'ai une question pour vous
parce que vous vous êtes très rassurant
mais moi j'adore jour d'hiver je vous
trouve quand même très optimiste sur le
fait en quelques minutes seulement cinq
heures vous allez résoudre et améliorer
la non il n'a pas dit ça y
est ce que parfois ces entités vous
résiste est-ce que parfois vous échouez
alors moi il m'est arrivé aussi
il m'est arrivé d'aller dans des
endroits où j'avais fait une émission
pour m6 par exemple et on avait trouvé
effectivement une entité dans cette
maison et la personne qui habitait ce
lieu avait confirmé tout ce que je
voyais tout ce que je disais et je lui
dis on fait quoi maintenant elle me dit
on fait rien parce que moi je suis très
bien avec elle
ça va doubler ils ont fait mariée au
premier regard
mais il ya en france qu'on réagit comme
ça il faut savoir qu'en angleterre en
écosse est partout encore les ondes des
gens qui achètent des maisons hantées
non exactement et la maison a plus de
valeur quand elle est en paix non parce
que là moi je me dis c'est invendable
maintenant le mec t'es acheté dans cette
image ça serait dur de la location après
hommage aura une question un peu tu
parles de 15 personnes candidat qui leur
tend dans l'émission les chefs
je n'ai 21h
[Rires]
nous parle de 15 faire ça est-ce que ça
concerne qu'un seul bloc où les gens de
l'autre partie de l'immeuble lourd parce
que ça c'est un immeuble de 200
personnes ça il ya 200 à paris a dit
qu'il n'ya pas grave tu perds c'est
qu'une banque n'est qu'une base élèves
par exemple qui à droite ou à gauche la
télé c'est un pad c'est que nos marques
c'est que ici c'est plusieurs ports et
c'est à dire c'est qu'une partie voilà
donc un côté a rapporté me mal non après
jean pas au courant je suis très
sollicitée oui voilà madame citer
d'autres étaient de l'autre côté alors
lentilles si elle reste dans l'immeuble
celle là elle est généralement dans un
périmètre assez bien défini ah ouais
donc elle va pas dans l'immeuble à côté
des très rares alors par contre ça
arrive quand un ami m'a par exemple des
entités sont décédées de la façon dont
les scellés depuis très longtemps et
elles elles suivent les personnes
qu'elle aime bien un don de temps en
temps il m'est arrivé de dire à
quelqu'un tient vous avez quelqu'un à
côté de vous qu'ils s'appellent pierre
et et roule et la personne ne dit c'est
mon grand père est décédé il ya quinze
jours
les gens à côté des entités à côté d'eux
des gens vous voyez thonex
les cacher
est-ce que vous maintenant voilà
maintenant que vous êtes là ces
questions qu'on se pose depuis de
nombreuses années dans son arrivée
maintenant vous nous donner la réponse
est ce que daniel est vraiment vivant
[Rires]
elle est vivante accueille là mais vous
voyez pas des gens autour de nous là
aujourd'hui
en fin de compte si vous voulez il ya
beaucoup de monde mais quand il ya
énormément de monde pour voir les
énergies et l'ont donc ça devient
compliqué quand même
quand on est en cercle restreint et qui
avait pas beaucoup de monde ça m'est
arrivé en radio comme je disais de
capter des personnes comme ça sur des
animateurs connus c'est injuste ans a
été dix fois celle des animateurs connus
ils avaient des entités derrière eux oui
qui s'agitent beaugrand christophe
c'était sympa son grand père c'était sur
une matinale sur virgin il m'avait
invité pour halloween et réprouve
rigoler en disant oui bah est ce que
vous êtes capable de nous dire si il ya
une entité là et puis je dis moi on
parle de quelqu'un s'appelle pierre seel
fou qui est décédé il ya pas longtemps
parce qu'ils sont en effet présents et
christophe a fait ou là c'est mon grand
père
mais la radio qui sera pas dans le dos
ah oui alors il était là je sais pas
pour
les élections on parle en tant que
gardien ça c'est un autre débat les
anges gardiens c'est intéressant ce
gardien c'est aussi souvent des
personnes qui sont décédées qui sont
proches de nous à l'ide est ce que vous
aimeriez que pierre wiehn haut niveau
moi ça me dérange pas
parce qu'on voulait faire quelque chose
allait faire il a fait réagir et oui ce
serait bien mais le maire a dit qu'il
allait
aller s'occuper de sa maison mère c'est
la norme et va écrire à l'entité vous
avez quinze jours
être logés au cas où quelqu'un enlève
les entités ouais et puis moi ou
quelqu'un irait forcément que ce soit de
sauvetage en 10 10 s'ils peuvent venir
il nous enlever ces entités bien sûr ça
serait pas oui